good morning Martinez thank you to each
and every one of you hardy souls to this
brave the snowpocalypse I grew up in
Minnesota and it never ceases to amaze
me the kind of hysteria that seasons the
Washington metro area but in advance of
a snowstorm we're grateful that you came
out this morning and looking forward to
to marking the the birthdays of both
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
today both of whom celebrated February
birthdays indeed have Presidents Day in
a little over a week's time and it's
good to recall that it's Congress still
and by law marks that is George
Washington's birthday we intend to do
that today as well my name is David Bob
I direct for the Kirby Center will sail
college were fresh off a event that was
held last weekend called the
Constitution Town Hall as some of you
may have participated in that because
well held in Chantilly Virginia was
available online still it's archived at
Constitution Town Hall calm wish to
check out that event we had more than
33,000 people register for the event and
that number has continued to grow as
people are expressing a real interest in
in thinking about the principles of the
of the Constitution and the duties
really of citizenship the Kirby Center
exists to do just that to educate
Americans about the principles and
practices
constitutionalism the kirby senator
based here in Washington is a program of
Hillsdale College a school that was
founded in 1844 Hillsdale is committed
to constitutionalism and it taught all
of its students take a course on the US
Constitution you can find the reader
that those students use online at the
Kirby Center dot or the Kirby centers
website and also find out more
information about pill sales other
programs there are programs for teachers
including a seminar coming up and people
bill sales campus and other things that
have just been announced for the summer
a series of hospitals and other programs
burger for citizens I would also just
mention to you that the first principles
on first Friday's series will continue
in March and we're pleased that Andrew
McCarthy from national online National
Review Institute and formerly the lead
prosecutor in the lion shake case in New
York City somebody who's been writing a
great deal very busy in the last couple
of weeks especially covering the Obama
administration and terrorism he's going
to speak on the topic America at war or
is it
that's the question really that we have
to confront are we at war against
Islamic radicalism and if so what does
that work constitute so that is Friday
March 5th same time in same place as
this morning's talk this morning were
really pleased to have with us a member
of Hillsdale colleges faculty an
assistant professor of history
Terence Moore is a lieutenant in the
Marine Corps I used the present tense
because I haven't told that talk once a
marine always a marine you can tell that
from the way that dr. Moore conducts his
classes but he does so with not only the
good and proper severity that topics he
teaches require but also an appreciation
of the
the liberal arts relief duly delivered
and for eight years he directed the
Ridgeview classical schools as principal
he was founding principal of that school
which was recognized by publications
both in Colorado and around the country
as amongst the leading schools they need
not just recognized that it really did
achieve that it's a school a public
school public charter school that
achieved significant results in what the
students were learning and it did so by
instructing them in the great books dr.
Moore I'm sure would be happy to tell
you more about that in a question and
answer period but this morning he's here
to speak to our two leading statesmen in
learning from Washington and integrate
talk about education specifically
Washington and Lincoln education
currently the most popular way of
thinking on the matter of public
education reform and the way adopted by
the president administration the logic
I'm afraid is shared by too many of
those who claim to be on the right of
the political spectrum run into
something like this jobs are important
we're in danger of losing jobs to
overseas competitors schools ought to
prepare young people for jobs kids
graduating from schools today are not
prepared for jobs the employers tell us
the teachers tell us that they cannot do
their jobs with the money they're given
and we all know the teachers
salt-of-the-earth for the most underpaid
profession in the world
so we need to spend a lot more money on
public education so we can create a
competitive workforce for the 21st
century in the global economy the jobs
of the 21st century require a lot of
skills since we now live in the
information age there's so much
information out there so we need to make
sure there's a lot of skill training in
this education other than that we don't
know too much about education let the
professionals take care of that the
details we'll sign the checks this is
the substance of all that has been said
from the political classes on the
subject of public education for the last
20 years the only difference between the
right and the left on education is that
the right occasionally grows in the term
choice and at the local level in a very
few places in this country they actually
provide the measure of choice too often
however if we may discuss later this
choice has no teeth what worries me
however is that the Obama administration
now appears to embrace choice
specifically in its friendliness toward
charter schools attended by the poorest
minority students can the left have
finally seen the light don't count on it
rather the left still controlled by the
public school establishment has learned
to manipulate the desire for choice on
the part of the parents and politicians
alike in order to funnel even more money
into the abyss that is the public school
system and the money will continue to
flow from hard-working taxpayers to bad
schools as long as the logic the train
of thought that I've outlined remains
unchallenged the most obvious flaw of
the logic is beginning with jobs and
moving backwards to dictate what ought
to be required of Education the argument
is flawed in this respect for several
reasons first though jobs are no doubt
an important factor in the happiness of
a person's life or in a nation's
flourishing they're not everything by
acquainting education to job worthy this
we can cut out all the other areas of
life such as
understanding or moral capacity or the
Faculty of language or the ability to
love another human being and any number
of other things that make up your life
in my life the hours of the week we're
not working and that guide our
intellectual and moral compasses as we
do work in fact the chief thinker in the
West who equated the person's job with
his happiness in life and his quality of
mine was none other than Karl Marx
second all the hullaballoo and and
reading about skills for a 21st century
workforce plays right into the hands of
the public school establishment since no
one can define what those skills are the
schools cannot be held accountable and
we are allowed to experiment wildly with
any theories emerges from the schools of
Education worries about the job market
cost politicians to throw money at the
problem when the worries increased
during an economic downturn were
collapsed education is the one area
no-one has the audacity to cut we're
still the rhetoric of skills allows
public schools to continue to do what
they have for the past 60 years or more
ignore content based on knowledge of the
time-tested subjects of history
literature physics trigonometry grammar
and so on the third floor logic is the
most critical looking at a particular
type of job or whole economy of jobs now
existing in order to shape the education
system is the most static view of
Education and the most static view of
economy anyone can offer no one can tell
us not Steve Jobs not Bill Gates not
Jack Welch and it's currently not
President Obama what sort of jobs will
be available 18 years from now
four-year-old will get the job work
considering skills is the only entrance
to the job market even very high skills
is akin to thinking recent high school
and college graduates show up every year
in a big hotel each one with a coded key
each one trying to get his a key to work
at some door or other if one key never
works
if the code has expired that person
doesn't get a room he has to go back to
the drawing board and redo his entire
training education or whatever we call
it now while no doubt skills at a higher
level play some part these skills ought
to rest on some fundamental learning
that allows people not just to adapt to
an ever-changing market but to make that
market for themselves
in other words jobs do not make the
human mind the human mind makes jobs
when a man's mind is well-trained is not
limited to the jobs that are out there
he puts himself in demand since there is
never a glut of people who can think
my point is instead that instead of
getting lost in the fog of skills and
jobs for the 21st century and the global
economy and all this claptrap is in
Obama's education agenda with training
human minds in the sure subjects at the
school level subjects that have been
tested in every information age we need
to be occupied this is what has made
every information age every industrial
age every enlightened age in history the
training of mind that in fact created
those ages our question should not be
how do we train young people for jobs
but rather how do we train a human mind
what does a well-trained mind look like
what are the very minimum things
everyone should know how much would a
minimal education cost and how long
should it last your answer some of these
questions it seems we might do welcome
wants to consult that surest guy who
live on
family fathers of this nation the lamp
of experience as they called it that is
history we have living examples of minds
that solve problems that use critical
thinking that uh service out of one age
and into another to a better age I have
in mind the two greatest presidents in
American history and arguably the two
greatest men those presidents and men
are George Washington and Abraham
Lincoln the one was the indispensable
man in that great revolution which
transformed thirteen separate colonies
into a united nation and a
constitutional border that became the
envy of the world
it has arguably done more good in the
world than any regime past or present
the other redeemed that nation from its
original sin the blight of slavery that
controlled the economy and eventually
the political culture of one half of it
might we learn from these two figures
what minimum education is required to do
great things in the world the first
astonishing fact we have to contend with
is that neither Washington nor Lincoln
was given any special advantages in
their early education every person in
this room has had more schooling than
Washington and Lincoln combined in fact
we could ruin the third greatest man in
American history in my opinion Benjamin
Franklin we could throw him into the mix
and still come up with less horrible
schooling for all three than what any of
us would have had by the time we
finished middle school moreover the
amount of money spent on a schooling of
all three for what we would now call the
high school age was exactly zero none of
them went to college though there were
excellent colleges to go to in both the
18th and 19th centuries in America the
paucity of our three greatest men
schooling should chase in a nation that
spends untold billions every year on
public education with negligible results
a nation by the way that teaches you
people very little about the amazing
lives of its three greatest and
unschooled men who are living proof of
the possibility of democracy you see the
lack of school experience for these men
exposes what the favorite philosopher of
the founding fathers john locke called
the false association of ideas a false
association is a connection a
relationship in the mind the gibson to a
person's head because he has grown up
with two things being constantly
connected in everyday speech though
these two things have nothing to do with
each other in our case one of the
greatest false associations of our time
is that between education and the one
hand and public schools on the other the
two in fact have at least in our time
not in all of history but in our time no
connection whatsoever the lives of
Washington and Lincoln prove that you
can get an education without going to
school and the lives of almost every
single young person today whether living
in an inner city or in the much-vaunted
suburbs proved you can go to school and
not education we should begin with
Washington's early education we know a
little about it
the most significant DeMint and the
young Washington's life the death of his
father when the young George was 11
ruined the young man's chances of
attending the Appleby school in England
as his father and two older
half-brothers had done before him the
exact nature of the young Washington's
early education is unclear
probably consisted in some training in
reading and writing under the tutelage
of private masters he also at errant end
of the school of a sort for a short time
we think yet the most beset of his
education is what it lacked an intense
study of the ancient languages that his
fellow Virginians Mason Jefferson and
Madison to name only a few
enjoy as a preparation for further
training in the languages and the formal
study of philosophy in college no doubt
Washington was reading and forming the
elegant
fighting style that now spans over 40
volumes of his complete works probably
using some of the same text written in
English that the better education
Jefferson and Madison would use there is
for example a reference in a copy book
of Washington's to his reading in an
unspecified English history up to the
ring the reign of King John and also
reading in The Spectator number one
Upton number 143 Addison and Steele
spectator of course was a favorite for
every boy in the english-speaking world
and we need only look to Franklin's
autobiography to see how that great work
could have been internalized and also
how to perform the person's writing
style because we know so little about
Washington's education it explains in
part why so much attention has been
placed on the young Washington's most
famous writing assignment is copying
down sometime before the age of sixteen
you think the now celebrated Rules of
Civility and decent behavior and company
and conversation in fact you have a copy
of these I made sure everybody doesn't
text in front of them I'm a college
teacher and people don't have a text in
front of them I get very very nervous if
you haven't done the reading that's okay
many of my students haven't done reading
when they've been declasse the writing
of these 110 rules which modern teachers
would consider a tedious exercise
lacking in spontaneity and imagination
may have served is an exercise in
penmanship we cannot forget that good
handwriting was far more important in an
agent laughs even the typewriter say
nothing in the computer the invocation
of speech through explicit acquisition
of polite words and phrases is clearly a
part of this exercise and we'll look at
some of those phrases letter for later
but of course that's something else
that's been abandoned by the public
schools
moreover the words and phrases of the
rules in Part II vocabularies
our speech the committing of these
sentences to paper though offers a small
illustration of a much larger
educational culture and habit of mind in
the 18th century the belief that there
were thoughts to be mastered often
passed down to us from a previous age
whose purpose was to guide our conduct
as we made our way in the world to this
end most every young gentleman kept
close at hand what was then called a
commonplace book a book in which were
written down particularly after striking
thoughts out of books read either in
study or for pleasure the idea is that a
thought committed to paper capable of
being reviewed from time to time will
stick in the mind become a habit serve a
man his entire life
these thoughts might have been is their
name suggests common places sometimes
they were taken from great passages in
the literature while others from simple
texts such as this list of rules
Washington wrote dating from the
Renaissance we should realize however
that what from an adult seems obvious
even commonplace to avoid may be a
revelation another word for commonplace
in short is wisdom let's look at
Washington's Rules of Civility some of
these are howlers my favorite is number
13 just turn the pages at the top kill
no bourbon his fleas lice ticks etc in
the side of others if you've seen any
bill or thick spittle put your foot
dexterously upon it and it be upon the
clothes of your companion put it off
private it and if it be upon your other
clothes return thanks to him who puts it
off some of the Hillsdale students who
are here on their internship they had
some fleas and ticks and lice and
spittle on their clothes but they all
put it off right
this rule teaches us as much about free
industrial hygiene as it does about
manners
we can easily cherry-pick our way
through the rules and have some good
laughs yet when we divest ourselves of
our own prejudices against the
backwardness of those times in so many
ways we see a larger moral first look at
the first rule and then the last the
first rule every action done in company
ought to be done with some sign of
respect to those who are present the
last rule labor to keep alive in your
breasts that little spark of celestial
fire all conscious do these pithy
statements not offer the whole reason
for in goal of polite manners and place
them in their proper frame of civilized
life the outer respect shown to those
that are present will eventually become
an internal habit of sold as a
Renaissance axiom has it manners maketh
the man seen from this perspective these
rules become imminently practical take a
look at number 12 right at the bottom of
the first page what does B do no man's
faith with your face with your spill
amount to if not an offense against
close talkers and therefore it's morally
a sensible shape not the head roll not
the eyes lift not one eyebrow higher
than the other right not the mouth all
service necessary injunctions against
what we mean we might call today teenage
attitude anyone who has been in the
ground teenagers has seen eyes roll in
eyebrows Lippe signs of being put out
rules and settled forms of conduct in
washington's world young men were
ushered into their roles as men by means
of pity
Maxim's seared into their remember
would not be too much to say moreover
that while Washington clearly did not
have the education of his contemporaries
so much so that in one of the snarky
comments we found among the founding
fathers a rather jealous John Adams
stated that Washington was to allure it
unread unlearning for the station and
reputation
the young Washington was in no way
outclassed in his reading and mastery of
maximum simple conduct in life in fact
Washington in his adult life showed a
kind of genius from axis and these
combined with his early training and
surveying which amounts to apply
geometry the favorite mathematics of the
grease and the strength of my strengthen
mine required to run a successful
plantation comprising many thousands of
acres these proved to be all the early
education Washington needed to fit very
well into his station and reputation now
I was standing the snipes of John Adams
who always ended up playing second
fiddle of course later in life
Washington did need to undertake a crash
course in the principles of natural law
under the tutelage of his fellow
Virginian and author of the Virginia
Declaration of Rights George Mason and
perhaps will explore that on another
occasion now there are these two things
to be said here about maxis the first is
that while Maxim's do not constitute a
philosophy they do give us first
principles principles that can be
applied to a variety of circumstances
throughout one's life let's take one
example of Washington's reliance upon
Maxim's that it first appears fairly
innocuous but in truth may have had
historical consequences writing to his
nephew and named namesake george step to
washington who was then 16 the uncle
offers this advice he's writing a letter
at this crisis your conduct will attract
the notice of those who are about me and
is the first impressions are
the most lasting your doings now they
mark the leading traits of your
character throughout life it is
therefore absolutely necessary if you
were to make any figure upon the stage
that you should take the first steps
right Washington goes on to urge his
nephew to acquire whoa a habit of
Industry any dis relish of that
profusion of money and dissipation of
time which are ever attended upon
idleness Washington devotes a large part
of the letter to discouraging the lad
not to spend too much money on plumbing
at any rate all the marks of Maxim
inculcation are here common phrases such
as first impressions and first steps the
metaphor of the stage is a man's place
in life one of Washington's favorite
metaphors and the emphasis on the
importance of what Jefferson would call
a decent respect to the opinions of
mankind no solid advice the letter would
strike this is no more than commonplace
where it not written by George
Washington but then there is the matter
of the date the 23rd of March 1789
that's just five weeks before George
Washington will be inaugurated as the
first President of the United States the
first president of its kind in history
so I'm going to reread read this letter
and think about this we're five weeks
away from the inauguration at this
crisis your conduct will attract the
notice of those who are about you and as
the first impressions are generally the
most lasting your doings now may mark
the leading traits of your character
throughout life it is therefore
absolutely necessary if you were to make
any figure upon the stage that you
should take the first steps right
there is to be sure in Washington's
world a crisis at hand the crisis of
whether a young nation can establish
itself among the community of nations
Washington and the entire nation are up
on the stage trying to prove that their
maximum of conduct will prove viable
even more telling the new nation suffers
from chronic debt his character would be
ruined if it cannot get out of debt it
can hardly afford either a profusion of
money for a dissipation of time given
the massive challenges in taking the
first steps toward a more perfect union
the Maxim's Washington internalized in
you that he is now passing on to his
young nephew moments before he takes
office will be the same that will guide
his every move while establishing the
character that is the American nation
now we might call us reflect in any
number of ways apply our own times but I
should only like to remark that though I
don't know that much about the early
education of President Obama or Nancy
Pelosi or Harry Reid I am fairly certain
that they missed the part about a dis
relish of that profusion of money
another way we could ask this question
is what Maxim's do we live by what
metaphors do our children internalize in
school that would they will live for for
the rest of their lives
what commonplace what wisdom is imparted
in school if you go throughout this if
you just go through this little writing
exercise and you circle the moral words
in it you will come up with words such
as unbecoming evil unjust malice in the
commendable passion reason are these are
these the words that we hear our young
teenagers and folks in their early
twenties using on occasion or with
regularity
let's go on to Lincoln we must really
say something of his education the first
thing that strikes us about Lincoln's
education that is from all his
contemporaries its how limited and even
little encouraged it was Lincoln had
little access to schooling the lack sets
of books and the Vitara until Sarah Bush
Lincoln entered his life his stepmother
at age 11 apparently little tolerance
for his natural inclination for books
our understanding of Lincoln's learning
the rings fixed by the self deprecating
account he provides in a campaign
autobiography in 1859 in which he said
he spent less than one full year in
school learned only reading riting and
rithmetic or rather cycling to the rule
of three rule of three by the way of
abortions if 3 is to 9
what if 3 is denying and what is one to
blame that's sight them to the rule of 3
interestingly enough they do Elementary
algebra problems sometimes a test ended
one assuming City University of New York
vo today 90% of the students failed
that's cycler into the rule of three at
any rate this little store of Education
which Lincoln speaks of had become far
more impressive by the time he reached
his memorable debates with Stephen
Douglas I wrote his first inaugural and
no doubt the ode to his own proclivities
and virtues yet we can also say a few
things about Lincoln's education that
reached beyond one man were one heaven
in our history perhaps we can even hold
to a few self-evident truths about the
nature of both education and democracy I
would hold that after the examples of
Washington and Franklin proved to the
world that quite like truly liberal
education based on the classes might be
held from a child due the circumstance
of birth or accident I would hold it in
a democracy there is no reason why a
child who has the least inkling for
learning should not obtain what was
called in the 18th century
English education that would allow an
adult functioning to thrive in the world
in both his occupation and in the
largest pursuits of citizenship and
culture the example of Lincoln
reiterates what that education might
consist in and how today's schools must
be utterly failing in their duties by
not providing at least the education
that Lincoln had when this great
Democratic story of self education is
right before them the inquiries into
Lincoln's early education that will
widespread in his time and in the
histories written after the Civil War
all ended up marveling at the abject
poverty of his educational resources his
access to books his attending schools by
littles as he put it not adding up even
to a year in the 21st century I think we
should take a different tack we should
rather more at the richness of Lincoln's
educational resources even as we marvel
at the poverty of our own in this much
celebrated Information Age let's do a
little experiment this is a pretty
educated audience I'm sure we have a few
degrees in here probably from some of
the best colleges and universities in
the country some graduate degrees
professional degrees whatnot we had
growing up even in advance of the
internet access to thousands maybe tens
of thousands of books we spent a little
more than a year in school we probably
spent 12 or 13 years in school how does
our primary or secondary education stack
up to Lincoln's log cabin learning well
figure this out by show of hands how
many of you of us before the age of 18
had read the whole of a complete edition
of Aesop's famous the whole edition of
Aesop's famous pants please okay Lincoln
had not just once the dozens of Tom's
how many of us had read the original
Robin Crusoe Robinson Crusoe by Daniel
Defoe not a tame down version but the
original three three others
Lincoln had more than once how many of
us had read Coburn's progress in its
entirety - that's pretty good 3 Lincoln
had how many of us had read some car to
cover and more than once the old Parson
Williams life of Washington his mouth
now mainly dismissed as a myth and is
known only for the cherry tree did
Washington didn't chop down you buddy
read that that was Lincoln's favorite
book and how many of us had read most if
not all the King James version of the
Bible one Shakespeare carbonate cover 20
the King James Version good one person
Lincoln had so this is not very
impressive but I'm sorry to say you
should go back and demand your money
back
Lincoln's Cadence's and Cadence's and
speeches and letters of proof that
nothing informed his style more than
that great moral and religious literary
wonder the King James Bible should I go
on did Lincoln a little more time into
his early 20s and he will have mastered
English grammar Euclid the Declaration
of Independence and the Constitution
while he continued to read fables and
reflect upon the lives of Washington
Franklin in Lincoln no and Jefferson he
reflected on his home life as well as
here and all these things allowed by the
way along with the speeches of Henry
Clay thus listening his way into a
perfect command of the English language
and internalizing the first principles
of morality politics and freedom
allowing one example one example of what
such an education could have been
stilled in a young boy on America's
frontier when I give you an account of
I'm going to give you three accounts of
Washington's Crossing the Delaware
here's the first one with which you
could be familiar know of course that
there was this crossing of the Delaware
by Washington in order to take the
Hessian outpost at Trenton Princeton and
thus maintain Patriot ground this is in
the close of 1776 here's the first
account General Howe firmly and
luxuriously based in New York
established outposts in New Jersey and
settled down to wait out the winter
Washington however was not yet ready to
go into winter quarters instead he
seized the initiative on Christmas night
1776 he slipped across the icy Delaware
with some 2,400 men near gone at Trenton
the Americans surprised a garrison of
1,500 Hessians German mercenaries still
befuddled from too much holiday rum it
was a total wrap from which only 500
royal soldiers escaped death were
captured only six of Washington's men
were women one of whom was lieutenant
James Monroe the future of the President
this account was taken from the fourth
edition of Tyndall in shai's America a
narrative probably the most popular
companion text to university courses in
American history then used by some of
the AP teachers in high school though
indisputably factually accurate I asked
you where is the mirror in beating up
some drunk Germans while the British
general this apparently kicking back in
his own befuddling in New York we move
on to the account given up Washington's
crossing and probably the favorite texts
of rich suburban high schools and posh
private day in boarding schools in this
free country Howard's ends of people's
history of the United States history
when she writes on frequently here he
goes Zim's
the Americans lost the first battles of
the war Bunker Hill Brooklyn Heights
Harlem ice the deep south
they won small battles at Princeton
Trenton and Princeton and then in a
turning point a big battle at Saratoga
New York in 1777 the short passage
constitutes the bulk of the account of
the war the gained American independence
would take too much time to go into the
errors of the specious listing about us
while we were given a few words on the
battle
when the war you're treated to a nice
account on the same page of how the
military conflict crowded out other
issues that were then going on one of
these issues being the distinction made
between officers admitted in
Washington's army new Lords new laws are
presented in quoting an unnamed chaplain
now I ask you you know if you haven't
figured it out then is a Marxist this
story and also before he died the other
day a multi-millionaire based on this
text which is read in our schools I
asked you was Washington commander of
the Continental Army with all his
thousands of acres in Virginia any less
cold than his poorest private on that
bitter night in 1776 when he personally
supervised the Delaware crossing for
hours on end when all was a blizzard
blizzard and in doubt I forget to
mention that this is also matt damon's
favorite-- now here's what Lincoln read
we use like Washington everything being
in readiness by Christmas night as soon
as it was dark they struck their tents
and moved off in high spirits once more
to try their fortunes against an enemy
long victorious but alas enthusiasm of
the gallant Kalibak Kalibak why litter
and Ewing was soon arrested for on
arriving at the river they found it so
filled with Isis to preclude all
possibility of crossover thus to they're
inexpensive inexpressible grief was
blasted the ardent wish to aid their
beloved chief in this last bold attempt
to save America ignorant of the failure
of 2/3 of his plan in Washington in his
little forlorn hope pressed on through
the darks at night pelted by the
incessant storm of hail and snow on
approaching the river nine miles above
Trenton they heard their unwelcome the
unwelcome roar of ice loud crashing
along the angry flood but the object
before them was too vast to allow one
thought about difficulties the troops
were instantly embarked and after five
hours of infinite toil in danger landed
some of them frostbitten on the same
shores of the
forming the line they renewed their
March you see the difference the account
continues and we're actually given
reason for these more than human
exertions pale and slowly moving along
the neighboring hills was seen by
fancies fine
the weeping genius of Liberty driven
from the rest of the world she had fled
to the wild woods of America as to an
assurance silent arrest here she finally
hooked through long than failing time to
see her children pursuing their cheerful
toils unstart and uncrushed by the
inhuman feud but alas the inhuman few
with fleets and armies had pursued her
flight one little band of the lone
remain and now resolved to defend her or
perish were in rapid march to face her
foes this account is highly rhetorical
and middle indeed it is veiled in a
buddy a nest allegory of Lady Liberty
being chased out of every land and
hunted down but I asked you at the three
accounts we have glanced at which is the
more accurate the bare narrative of
facts or the brief mention of the battle
framed by complaints against the
military and social inequalities alleged
by Marxist living in luxury two hundred
years later where the lyrical words of
parson Weems replete with heroism and an
ultimate cause which one is true which
one captures the hardships of hopes and
the ultimate ends of those men who knew
in that bitterly cold history changing
night of December 1776 what was at stake
not only for themselves but for millions
yet unborn
we know the account given by liens made
an impression on Lincoln on his way to
becoming president of the United States
Lincoln passed through New Jersey and
had this to say to the Senate of that
state may I be pardoned if
on this occasion I mentioned that way
back in my childhood the earliest days
of my being able to read I got pulled of
a small book such as one as few of the
younger members have ever seen memes is
life of Washington I remember all the
accounts they're given of the
battlefields and struggles for the
liberties of the country and none fixed
themselves upon my imagination so deeply
as the struggle here at Trenton New
Jersey the crossing of the river the
contest with the Hessians the great
hardships endured at that time all fix
themselves on my memory more than any
single revolutionary event and you all
know for you've evolved in boys now
these early impressions last longer than
all the others I recollect thinking then
boy even though I was that there must
have been something more than common
that those men struggled for there's
something even more than natural
independence it's something that held
out that a great promise to all the
people in the world for all time to come
Lincoln's reflections on memes Mike
Lincoln's boyhood reading been the
source of those mystic chords of memory
binding the nation together Lincoln
spoke up in the first normally is so
presumably more men than Lincoln and
those impressions forged into their
memories and drew upon those memories
marching into battle to save that genius
of Liberty we've been hunting around the
globe and even in part of that great
beacon of Liberty the United States
which brings me to my final question
what memories of Washington of Lincoln
of this nation of Liberty constitute our
early impressions in education a man
without any memories is like a man with
amnesia the world has the world can only
be a mystery to him a man who develops
in his youth a seething hatred for the
place he calls home though he may have
skills though he may have by the
standards of the day
and education such a man can be nothing
but dangerous my thesis is that
President Obama has become friendly to
so-called schools of choice because he
knows the potential as such schools and
as he is a former and present community
organizer this such schools can be good
really good
and inculcating radical ideas the virtue
of the schools as they exist now as
public schools have few virtues is
they're not doing anything particularly
well they can't teach you how to read
they can't teach you how to be a good
Marxist but if schools of choice can
become hotbeds radicalism in the inner
city that could be a dangerous thing
indeed I think the riot needs to spend
more time talking about not only the
choice that the school system ought to
have an immediate needs choice it needs
to talk about the substance of the
education that we should be embarking
upon
all right thank you listening any
questions this gentleman back here has
one yes sir
i reduced letting my daughter be dating
howard zinn but i was wondering what I
should have replaced them with what
would you well that's tough because
there there is no good one volume
American history textbook there is the
Patriots history now which is good if
you really want to know what these men
suffered especially at Valley Forge I
would go back and read a different
people's history of the United States
one by Paige Smith you familiar with
that first came out of the 17 in 1976
and I reread that over the summer is
excellent on all the all the battles in
particular it's a first-class military
history and it's a narrative it's long
but young people have nothing other than
their hands so get them away from their
cell phones give them those volumes of
payment yes ma'am I couldn't help but
notice you using the phrase oh well well
training minors wondering if you can
also read the book by the same title and
then along with that
possible education which of course
anchors kids in the classics ending in
history when having kind of that
worldview and so I mean I to me this
just seems like a perfect way to to go
in these charter schools that make them
classical schools obviously they're very
strong as much as possible we have
Christians who were classically educated
to give it that solid foundation because
of course a classical school you would
be throwing out the pedestal textbooks
and bringing in the classics and then
you could be selecting things that have
the right yes I mean I totally agree I
have read both welcome on which I say is
written by the ladies wise Susan wines
Bowery Boys they're they're wise ladies
and classical education is very strong I
ran a classical school for seven years
as a classical charter school I will say
that the classical schools and even the
the wise ladies make one mistake and
that is they become so classical that
they start churning out latinus and they
forget the American narrative if you
look at some of the critical in these
classical schools they think they give
kids the education that Madison would
have had but they don't give too much on
the American story and my version of
classical education would be to build up
and to make the American story in fact
the the premier thing because classical
education would be truly classical has
to be an education and citizenship and
so while we need the cultivation it was
wrong we also need to be connected
our own civil polity which is the United
States that's that's what I call their
eventually I think Hillsdale will have
same things to say about that as we
starting our own initiative in in that
realm yes sir Washington presided over
the Constitutional Convention and
Lincoln was a self constitutional
scholar our current president is also a
constitutional law professor and he's
invited my alma mater really I'm curious
like I see your thoughts on the
disparity and the huge difference
between their understanding of the
Constitution well I'm glad you bring up
bring that up is actually your question
with a previous lady's question or is
Harlan connected the attack on the
public schools that had been pretty good
in in the early part of the 20th century
was an attack waged by what we now call
progressive education which is a part of
the progressive movement the other
attack that took place was an attack on
the Constitution also a part of the
progressive movement so the kind of
constitutional law that President Obama
practice at the University of Chicago
Law School is not constitutional law in
how we would understand that it's it's
an anti constitutional law similarly the
education that the founding fathers had
had which gets even better to move past
Washington and start looking at what
Madison study that is also under attack
because it's that well-ordered mind that
leads to the understanding of natural
law in a constitutional order it has to
be attacked if the progressive movement
is
to be victorious so it's not just that
we've stumbled into some bad ideas in
the public school system it's that this
is a conscious effort to to lay siege to
the mind that would come up with the
sort of ideas that Washington Jefferson
or a Lincoln with Hannah so I you see
you see what I was saying here the the
the term progressive either in
progressive education or progressive
politics is a conspiracy I guess to
dismantle dismantle the founding fathers
and to completely change the language
now they talk about rights for example
when they're talking about rights are
not talking about natural rights is
understood by Jefferson at all you know
they're talking about entitlements which
are things taken from people so and of
course you have to get entitlements we
have to take them from some people and
that means those people's rights have to
be violated we could go into this in
some detail is that enough for right now
okay good yes ma'am I'm wondering what
your opinion is on the International
Baccalaureate curriculum personally I
think that is very complete and do you
see it eventually replacing the high
school
when I tried me politic I understand
that there's a little bit of variety in
the International Baccalaureate
curriculum but understand what it is
it's international it's trying to be a
world curriculum therefore it's not
situating itself in the American polity
in the American experience now I've
known I haven't looked at it
systematically but I do know parents of
kids who have gone through it and this
could be the flavor of the place it may
not have refer to every Ivy program in
country but I know that it can be
extremely India America and it can also
be extremely and Christian with the you
know the promises this player of
internationalism which is very much part
of the Obama s in fact I would say that
the idea is the very opposite of what
Jefferson had in mind when he started
creating school colleges for Virginia
it's it's actually based in the classics
and I guess the the use of the word
international to label it as they do in
the United States you know I think about
the war in Honduras and the education
program to me it's very well-rounded and
it
it has a lot of foundation in the
classics but I guess it very well may be
that here it has been tainted if I
understand what you're saying
the Ivy program may be better overall
and in our own country it's turned into
a way to in some cases I know this to be
true
bash America so you could be very proud
I I just I would not call it a classical
education because the classical
education is always rooted one's own set
of politic and I don't know it to be
based on the classics meaning the
learning that comes out of the recent
Romans maybe it is but that's that's not
what is up happening in some of the
districts that I know over the news on
you I should look at it into more more
in-depth but I I know that in terms of
its level of sophistication far
outclasses with schools public schools
nowadays I mean that that goes without
saying our only competition which I when
I was in Fort Collins was the IB program
is we're being taken
I'm going back to college but I noticed
when I speak to people who are teachers
they say well we're mainly teaching for
the test so the high schoolers will pass
the SATs and get good scores and used a
lot of terms that are kind of lucky in
education news you go to they will say
that they were teaching students how to
think and they will say that their
inculcating thinking skills now I've
never understood what a thinking skill
is in the old days you just call it
thought
apparently there's a skill out there
think I'm gonna find that skill one day
and work on the problem the thing that's
missing is the idea of actual knowledge
that has to be quiet which is really at
the heart of what you're trying to get
at my question
see it's the schools they want to talk
about the thinking skills and they know
they're always pounding you know
pounding us with these with the salsa
Society of the global economy and we're
gonna be outclassed and all the rest of
it instead of just going back to what
people need to know and I'm the most
articulate spokesman on this is actually
a man at the left and that's Edie Hirsch
who says there are things that we have
to know as a culture to be you will
communicate and his most recent book
he's actually fairly political moody
calls the making of America's where he
says you know the progressives have just
completely lost in the idea
common culture for civil polity so
you're absolutely right if there were to
be true education reform and there were
to be tests involved then we would have
to be tested on actual things actual
pieces of knowledge now no one wants to
do that of course why who has been you
get into the culture force
so imagine if we were to have the
discussion about what should be the what
should be the requirements on such a
test this would be hotly disputed we
would be told of it you know it's auntie
pour insanity black and Hispanic so on
and so forth because you know these are
just culturally determined things there
was another talk I was gonna give before
I got snowed out today let me give you a
sample of a thing of what would have
been on a college entrance test in the
year 1888 this is what we would have to
know to get into college the college in
the south history of the United States
you're just given the questions how many
point inches did Columbus made to
America give the date of each name the
13 original States named awards the
colonies were engaged in before the
Revolution named the presidents in order
to Cleveland in place opposite the name
of each the length of time in office did
the cause of the war of 1812 and the
Mexican War mentioned the important
facts of the Jackson administration name
the principal battles of the Civil War
and give the names of the principal
generals that's history lesson Jonathan
through what waters would you pass in
going by steamer from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania to st. Petersburg Russia
making the principle base that touched
the United States ready for some grammar
defining the parts of speech and give an
example of each
of your own composition give a sentence
containing the verb in the active voice
and then change it to the passive also a
sentence using the infinitive as a noun
also two sentences showing that the same
word may be used as an adjective and a
noun
those are just sample questions of what
it took to get into college
a southern college any guess what
college in your 1888
how about Georgia Tech I won't ask you
to math class more than cycling beyond
the rule of three
so that buildings are the things that
should be on the test and the grammars
actually should be non-controversial but
of course then you get argument hit with
your argument all this is standard
grammar which is you know quite may or
did like God Lincoln conscious rambles
you see what I mean so as soon as you
start actually asking and here's my
theory about the tests because I've seen
students go through these tests and
these are students at a school where
they've been reading Shakespeare and in
Cicero and all these things you know for
all of the year we took not one day to
prepare these tests because they were
such an insult and the students would
come at the test saying what a gentleman
it was like a day where they didn't have
to go to work right and here's a here's
a sample question that you would get on
one of these tests so from in the tenth
grade writing essay telling us about a
favorite hero of yours that's it
well notice that you didn't say anybody
you don't have to run on Lincoln
Washington you could write on your
father those tests are usually not check
for grammar right so so that anybody can
who is semi-literate can get pretty
close on those tests if you were to have
a real test the test real knowledge is a
matter of the state testing you would
see such
between the very very few good schools
which are almost all charter if they're
public and and everyone else in fact we
see massive failure in the eighties and
90% so we're not going to get a real
test and that's why they they hate the
test so much we don't want to teach to
the test what what else is public
education is supposed to do other than
teach to the test isn't that how we know
if someone has acquired something I mean
you can talk about thinking skills yes
but to get to at least to get to a
portion where you can think about
something that's in the text you have to
know certain facts right so you know the
the tests are inadequate and the tests
are merely designed I think even though
they've been forced on the public school
establishment since they've just been
turned over to the public school
establishment they actually hide more
than they shows and that's how you can
move into a suburban school districts
say you know the best scores in the area
of course they have the best scores
because you're preparing first of all to
the total social dislocation of the
university but on top of that you know
they come out in the 40th percentile
50th percentile what's the kids passing
you're not worried about it because you
think you're safe in the suburbs if this
were a real test even asking us to
cipher to the rule of three and 95% of
the kids can't do it then we would know
the truth about our public schools sorry
I'm a little warm on that question
and that Fox right or not we have time
for one more question yeah this will be
fun
okay this is this lady in the in the
back there President Obama has said that
his cutting heads for making decisions
like what works and I'm wondering how
would you say you define what works and
how does this differ from a liberal arts
way of viewing the world okay what works
is actually code if you go back and if
you look at FDR's administration he came
in saying the same thing in other words
we're not going to get caught up in
principles we're not going to get up in
we're not going to be caught up in
constitutional truths we're just going
to do what works and this is what FDR
said as he unveiled an agenda which was
clearly left-of-center which clearly was
not working and clearly bothered any
true constitutional scholar in the
nation and what's funny about that
because I spent a little time on
textbooks if you go back and you just
read the standard text books that deal
with the FDR administration they all say
the same thing
virtually verbatim they will say FDR was
a pragmatist
FDR just wanted to do what works that
was the rhetoric of FDR
look at his 1944 State of the Union
speech where he unveils what can only be
called a socialist regime ten years into
the Depression more than ten years into
the depression and it wasn't working you
see what I mean
and so the rhetoric of Obama is of
course we're just gonna do what works
what that means is we don't have to do
anything looks remotely constitutional
but it's not working you see what I mean
it's funny but principles are important
I know this lecture series is called
first principles but when I was running
a school I had some of those type people
even sometimes on the board and they
were kind of not to offend anyone in the
audience with engineering types where
they would say oh let's just fix it
there's a problem let's just fix it
let's not talk about philosophy
it's not about principles as soon as you
take the principles out of it and think
you can just fix it it's going to turn
into a popularity contest if you truly
believe that but usually what it's doing
is hiding your religion because I think
Obama knows exactly and then there's no
the language of pragmatism pragmatism is
just the perfect rhetoric to trick
Americans who one of their great virtues
is at their practical pragmatic but
American is actually when they're at
their best are following first
principles in the same way that Lincoln
said that he had nothing there was
nothing about his political philosophy
that did not go back to the Declaration
of Independence when's the last time
we've had a president say that do we
read the Declaration of Independence I
mean this is this is insane
but I can one of the sure test that you
can give to average almost any public
school a student coming out of public
schools is you can quote either the
beginning of the declaration or the
beginning of the Constitution just ask
them what call the document is from and
they won't know and they will guess
they'll say the Constitution where
they'll say the Declaration but they
will not even know which one it is so
how in the world can we get back to
first principles when we don't reward
even reading the first principles all
right thank you thank you for your
questions and thank you